great to be here and to be together
again yeah it's great I'm also here to
pick up my monthly check under the Jedi
pension plan apparently they never rent
[Music]
okay
bb-8 wants to know why he's the only one
not in a tuxedo it's delicate no
designer would dress him ma'am
I think it's robot discrimination no
that's the thing is it okay this next
award is for the films that follow the
rule brevity is the soul of wit here are
the nominees for best animated short
film dear basketball Glen Keane and Kobe
Bryant
garden party Victor Cary and Gaby el
rapido
new Dave Mullins and Dana Marie negative
space max Porter
revolting rhymes Jacob shoe and yonder
howl and the Oscar goes to
don't say la-la land don't say la-la
land dear basketball glenn key
[Applause]
when King and Kobe Bryant
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you thank you Academy Thank You
Jenny around max Keene our entire crew
for your incredible talents my life
Linda for your years of love and support
and takobi for writing dear basketball
it's a message for all of us whatever
form your dream may take it's through
passion and perseverance that the
impossible is possible I don't know if
it's possible I'm as basketball players
we're really supposed to shut up in
dribble but I'm glad I'm glad we do a
little bit more than that
Thank You Academy for this amazing honor
thank you John Williams for such a
wonderful piece of music thank you
Verizon for believing in the film Thank
You Molly Carter without you we wouldn't
be here in two my wife Vanessa our
daughters Natalia Gianna and Bianca
Tiamo prone to Tonio quarter you are my
inspiration thank you so much
[Applause]